and I'm looking out the door I feel like
the dog looking at me stay over there
dodo come this way
my heart was just pounding everything
was becoming so much
I use the bathroom and I'm thinking like
what if I just flush all it is is just
go home you know and say I lost it or
something but I'm just thinking I am you
know I laugh to myself are you crazy
this is a man you knew my apartment my
mommy gave me my friends so I just
chopped it up and felt like okay the
thing is they're not you know I have to
go through with it
the moment I see Maria I'm just thinking
thank god she's here she didn't make no
eye contact with me she didn't look at
me
you know she played her part pretty damn
well one of my main concerns was that
one of the other security guards near
her we're gonna be finished and if they
would have been finished they would have
just told me that you know that me
Sascha
well I just pray nothing was right I've
been her like she's about to search me
everything's good so I walk up to her
and I pull my
she has been actually pretty rough she
was you know attacking me real hard
grabbing me I was looking out like okay
but then as I saw how the other security
guards they all kind of was a little
aggressive so I'm thinking maybe they
have to be this way when she comes down
towards my brush she stops this is I
what is that
I was like nothing
what
manga conmigo she was like come with me
and I give her the look like you gotta
be kidding me right now being evil
the pills never wear off yet I'm trying
to be positive on every level okay maybe
she has to do this maybe this is part of
the routine
the first thing she does is she goes
into the bra and she pulls out the
package
I'm thinking like okay maybe she has to
do this maybe she's supposed to do this
like I'm just kind of confused at the
moment I guess the pills we like to
savor for me to keep me from worrying
she takes out the package in the back he
turns me around and she does it
also in the front
she's like sit down he gets on the phone
she was like I need you to come into the
session and I'm looking out with this
face like [ __ ] this better be a part
you know of the plan